please welcome Michael Moore oh oh look  at the fog machine Mike it's really  working for you then where are you might  actually look it looks it looks more  like your front lawn all 4:00 in the  morning  no no where are you no I mean uh I I  mean I'm in Traverse City Michigan up  here in northern Michigan this part of  Michigan back in two thousand voters  overwhelmingly for george w bush and but  i think there's been a big turn here and  i expect us some good results on tuesday  yeah this is actually i'm just in the  neighborhood here it's Halloween and  these good people let us set up here the  camera and everything and and i asked  who these guys were and they said they  were McCain's last two supporters in  michigan